i am jesse dollamore sitting in for
david while he is on vacation uh hey
listen if you've been enjoying
the the look of my stupid face and the
sound of my dumb voice
i would encourage you to click the links
in the top of the description there and
uh check out where you can find me on
social media and on youtube
you know one of the
the
the major drawbacks of the political
divide that has largely been created by
donald trump at his camp is the fact
that
truth is no longer truth science is no
longer respected that kind of has been
the case with the republican party for a
long time
but it has really hit a fever pitch
under donald trump and this new
fascistic version of the republican
party
and in part of that is
obviously vaccine hesitancy which is
born out of a contempt
for expertise and a contempt
for science
they mock the educated they they are
they are
pleased as punch to be
the poorly educated remember when donald
trump said that on the campaign trail i
love
we love the poorly educated we won the
evangelicals we won with young
we won with old
we won with highly educated we won with
poorly educated i love the poorly
educated
and
one of the the downfalls of america
being such a touchstone culturally
across the globe is the fact that our
idiots
uh
are idiots uh are contagious and they it
leads to vaccine hesitancy and
anti-science views
even outside of the the borders of the
united states
enter the story from reuters which is
tragic
and scary
suspected saline switch sparks vaccine
stir
in germany
authorities in northern germany appealed
to thousands of people on tuesday
to get another shot of covid19 vaccine
after a police investigation found that
a red cross nurse
may have injected them with a saline
solution
in place of
a covid vaccine
adding to the hysteria and the fear here
is that this nurse is suspected of
injecting salt solution into people's
arms instead of genuine doses at a
vaccine center in friesland a rural
district near the north sea coast in the
early spring
and the early spring is the element of
this that is really a bummer because
that was when
the elderly on mass were getting
vaccinated to go back and start living
their lives with far less trepidation
and worry that they might catch the
disease
and be hospitalized or die
quote i'm totally shocked by this
episode end quote sven ambrosi a local
counselor said on facebook as local
authorities issued the call to around 8
600 residents who may have been affected
while saline solution is harmless most
people who got vaccinated in germany in
march and april when the suspected
switch took place
are elderly people
at high risk of catching the potentially
fatal viral disease
the motive of the nurse who was not
named was not clear
but she had aired skeptical views about
vaccines and social media posts police
investigators said
it was not immediately clear whether the
suspect had been arrested or charged in
the case which according to broadcaster
ndr has been handed to a special unit
that investigates politically
motivated
crimes
that
is sad
that health care
that a
a a a a a vaccine with
proven efficacy
has been turned into some kind of
political football
among conspiracy theorists
and chaos stirrers
as it is in the case of the american
political system
this isn't a political issue
this is a global health crisis the likes
of which we haven't seen for a hundred
years
and because of
idiots who want to maintain political
power
culture warriors
things like this are happening
this could be laid directly at the feet
of the republican party even though it's
foreign